bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être chaud grect avec nous sur rt
france pour débattre de l'actualité
politique alors on a vu où on a vu ces
jeunes qui ont conversé hier avec les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
il ya eu un sondage aussi qui montre que
si une partie des jeunes se
désintéressent de la politique et de
l'élection présidentielle
le dernier sondage ipsos réalisé pour la
fage montre que 8 jeunes sur 10
envisagent d'aller voter en avril 2022
c'est un chiffre plutôt encourageant
valérie de bord oui moi je trouve que
c'est vraiment effectivement c'est pas
tous forcément cependant cette hôtesse
qui était intéressant également dans son
match était la préoccupation est envoyé
que leurs préoccupations elle tournait
autour
du pouvoir d'achat de l'environnement de
la sécurité afin que somme toute
contrairement à ce qu'on peut peut-être
penser les préoccupations des jeunes se
rapproche aussi de celle de leurs aînés
en tout cas c'est plutôt rassurant de se
dire que la plupart d'entre eux la très
grande majorité d'entre eux va aller
voter alors on verra si ça se concrétise
arnaud belattar votre sentiment
bah écoutez moi je pense que c'est une
excellente nouvelle que les sondages
d'opinion montrent que 8 jeunes sur 10
sont prêts à aller voter c'est d'autant
plus encourageant que nous dans la
stratégie qu'on a mise en place à le
client populaire on compte énormément
sur le vote de cette jeunesse puisque du
coup c'est effectivement un pacte que
propose pour l'avenir puisque lien
populaire propose de mettre en place la
6ème république de remettre des
institutions plus démocratiques de
projet la planification écologique est
donc de faire le partage de la richesse
surtout quand on a vu à quel point
pendant la pandémie c'est notre jeunesse
qui était la plus touchée quand on a vu
que on a énormément de cette jeunesse
étudiante et de travailleurs précaires
qui dépendaient de l'aide alimentaire
pendant cette période donc effectivement
c'est un signal extrêmement
encourageants sur lesquels nous on
encourage les jeunes à aller voter
d'autant plus qu'on a organisé aussi eu
pas mal de caravanes de l'union
populaire pour mettre en place et bien
les inscriptions sur les listes
électorales parce qu'on encore
malheureusement trop concitoyens qui
sont pas ou mal inscrits pour l'élection
présidentielle on va parler d'un autre
sondage qui a été publiée ce matin celui
là il concerne valérie pécresse veut il
concerne pas que valérie pécresse mais
en tout cas valérie pécresse qui dévisse
ce matin là elle est à 11 5 vous allez
voir elle perd deux points et demi en
quatrième position donc derrière marine
le pen eric zemmour et bien sûr emmanuel
macron un commentaire valérie de bord
sur ce sur ce sondage qui n'est qu'un
sondage évidemment à un instant t je
précise oui écouter le commentaire et il
va s'acheminer vers ce que vous venez
d'indiquer il ya d'autres sondages ou
qui sont sortis hier où anita 14 à 14 et
demi parce qu'ils font
est important aujourd'hui si vous voulez
c'est que la campagne tant que le
président de la république en exercice
n'est pas rentrer en campagne la
campagne n'a pas réellement commencé on
voit bien autour de nous si vous voulez
on est sur les marchés on est présent
partout les français ne sont pas encore
complètement les vacances sont en train
de se dérouler notamment sur un certain
nombre de territoires donc on doit
aujourd'hui rentré dans cette real
campagne la campagne elle va commencer
quand elle va commencer à partir du
moment où les parrainages aux coutures
et est donc ça c'est le 7 mars et c'est
à partir de là en fait que les français
auront la photographie des réelles
candidats vont réellement concourir ils
ont clairement aussi et bien le
sentiment que tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui en train d'échanger ne
seront pas forcément au rendez vous et
donc ils vont commencer à s'intéresser à
ce moment là et à ce moment là des
propositions d'adhérer pécresse on
évoquer les jeunes elle propose
notamment le permis à 16 ans et en
termes d'autonomie de responsabilité de
capacité de rentrer dans le monde de la
formation et également par exemple
d'aller à l'université c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement positif donc à
beaucoup de choses qui vont pouvoir se
mettre en place la précampagne elle
commence après le décompte des
parrainages à arnaud guven à tam celle
inverse pour jean luc mélenchon qui qui
poursuit lui sa dynamique il est à mon
sens il gagne un demi point ce matin il
fait la course en tête à gauche alors
vous avez toujours dit vous méfier des
sondages mais que pensez vous de celui
là est ce qu'il reflète la réalité
en tout cas ce sondage lorsque en
parallèle avec d'autres enquêtes
d'opinion qui sont réalisés sur des taux
de participation côte est différent tous
montrent un jean luc mélenchon en
dynamique et au-dessus de 10% donc sur
une tendance générale qu'on observe à la
fois dans les sondages mais à la fois
sur le terrain lorsqu'on va en porte à
porte quand on veut faire des tractages
ou déboîtage on voit que
le peuple de gauche en général
commencent à s'intéresser à l'élection
présidentielle et il se trouve que
effectivement à ce stade est parce qu on
a commencé une campagne de conviction il
ya maintenant quasiment deux ans eh bien
avec un programme complet que les gens
identifient avec une figure que les gens
connaissent un taux sera pas se mentir
un gars très peu de gens finalement que
les gens connaissent sur les marchés car
ils connaissent le présent la république
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
c'est des grandes figures de la delà de
la vie politique française bien autour
de jean luc mélenchon est en train de se
cristalliser une certitude de vote parce
que le candidat ait connu parce que les
grandes lignes du programme sont
partagés le vote jean luc mélenchon en
2007 est un vote d'adhésion et non pas
un vote utile comme ça a pu être le cas
de des bannières de ma croire 2007 et
donc on reconstitue cette force on était
au même étiage à la même période en 2010
est en début d'année 2005 voire même
encore derrière benoît hamon à cette
époque et donc la tortue électorale
mélenchon va continuer de monter jusqu'à
nous on pense que ça va arriver au
second tour le trou de souris qu'on
avait identifiées il ya quelques mois
est en train de s'élargir puisque en
fait valérie pécresse s'effondre il ya
un match qui se joue entre pécresse
zemmour et le pen qui se départagent pas
puisque finalement tout se disant peu la
même chose on voyait devant le droit
d'écouter ma peine et dans ce sondage à
18% dans un certain nombre d'autres
sondages je pense notamment à cluster 17
chez marianne on voit que mélenchon
pécresse zemmour à la peine se tiennent
en deux points
mélenchon est dans cette dynamique là
est pour l'instant le seul à gauche
antinomiques une forte probabilité que
le score des mélenchon a explosé dans le
courant du mois de mars après des débats
et des grands mythes et les grands
messieurs on verra cela en tout cas nos
goûts et matam vous avez parlé du vote
utile ou ce n'avait pas été le cas pour
jean luc mélenchon lors de la précédente
présidentielle ségolène royal elle dit
le contraire elle le soutient regardez
il faut qu'il y ait un vrai débat au
deuxième tour et pas une nouvelle fois
juste une mobilisation pour faire un
vote de barrage contre l'extrême droite
à droite le vote utile c'est valérie
pécresse et à gauche c'est jean luc
mélenchon que pensez vous de ce soutien
de ségolène royal
ah bah écoutez nous on accueille toutes
les personnes qui y sont volontaires
pour mettre en place le programme de la
vie en commun a coûté on va pas
commencer on va commencer à dire à faire
le tri de ce qu'ils ont fait hier je
crois que ya une certaine conscience qui
c'est qui s'est déployé ces dernières
semaines qui est qui tend à montrer
qu'effectivement comme je les dis le le
vote jean luc mélenchon c'est pas un
vote utile c'est voter site est ce que
c'est un autre nécessaire puisqu'il faut
qu'on ait réellement un vrai débat
idéologique ou deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle ce que l'on
n'aura pas si on a macron pécresse sur
la macro le plein alors on va continuer
on va parler évidemment des parrainages
varié de valérie de bord le vote utile
c'est pécresse a dit également ségolène
royal c'est le cas
oui ce que je peux pas laisser dire
cette espèce de mythologie
macro et presse le programme de valérie
pécresse n'a strictement rien à voir
avec l'échec de dix années parce qu'en
fait maintenant si elle fait dix années
que monsieur macro est au pouvoir
aujourd'hui nos propositions en matière
économique nos propositions en matière
européenne de proposition sur la
jeunesse d'une strictement rien à voir
avec ce que fait le président de la
république nous avons un groupe à
l'assemblée qui si vous l'osez le façon
systématique je vous ai pas interrompu
si vous payez soyez la parole
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui nous avons
un groupe à l'assemblée nationale qui
s'opposent nous avons un groupe
évidemment une sommes majoritaires au
sénat dans cette considération nous
sommes présents sur tous les territoires
où nous sommes le parti
des territoires avec la plus grande
présence d'élus locaux et nous avons
aussi une volonté forte de
décentralisation de faire un acte iii
décentralisation qui est extrêmement
éloignée la verticalité du pouvoir tel
qu'elle est exercée aujourd'hui par le
président sortant et encore une fois les
derniers soutiens du président sortant
sont particulièrement socialiste excusez
moi de le dire ainsi et ils ne sont
absolument pas ancrée dans le camp de la
droite et du centre quand les choses en
la matière sont particulièrement clair
je comprends tout à fait cette petite
musique et cette volonté de pouvoir
essayer de la mettre en avant les
français ne sont pas dupes vous savez
tout comme ils savent que les vrais
candidats c'est à partir du 7 mars ils
savent très bien que le trajet et la
volonté de valérie pécresse elle
s'inscrit dans la dynamique de la droite
du centre et pas dans ceux en même temps
qui n'a ni saveur ni odeur de l'actuel
président alors en réaction arnaud
granata bon écoutez on a eu quand même
le deux premiers ministres qui sont
issus de vos reins edouard philippe jean
castex un onguent city pléthorique de
gens venant à droite qui sont en train
de faire allégeance emmanuel macron
ministre ancien ministre de la gauche
qui viennent de rallier emmanuel macron
oui c'est des gens alors marisol
touraine marisol touraine était candidat
de la république en marchant de cette
maison de type donc c'est pas vraiment
un nouveau soutien
que emmanuel macron se soit fait élire
en 2007 sur l'évolution qui porte des
idées de gauche la traite dit jean luc
mélenchon lui dit vous avez craché du
sang et des larmes c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé emmanuel macron a été
d'une brutalité son nom il ay là il a
réalisé des réformes que la droite
républicaine n'avait pas osé cher il
n'avait pas de majorité populaire pour
le faire à l'époque on pense aux
ordonnances travail on pense à la
réforme des chez nous on pense à tout un
tas de réformes que à la droite était
bien en peine à l'assemblée de conflit
puisque c'étaient des choses sur
lesquelles il était attendu quand il
était au pouvoir
le candidat de la droite clairement
c'est sait manier de maquereaux alors il
ya effectivement valérie pécresse qui
conduit à ces difficultés à 11% les
retrouve pas ce que c'est effectivement
toutes les enquêtes de
là dessus si vous qui est en difficulté
ce qui capte le vote dlr on a appris
dans le jdd qu'une douzaine de sénateurs
étaient aussi séduit par par eric
zemmour il pourrait même fondé un groupe
parlementaire autonome valérie de bord
c'est un vrai risque c'est un raccourci
si je puis me permettre j'ai lu cet
article tout comme vous et la meilleure
réponse était celle qui a donné à la
houe père en recevant valérie pécresse
et et ses soutiens je pense si vous
voulez il ya beaucoup de choses et c'est
normal on est en campagne électorale
choses qui se disent il ya beaucoup de
gens qui s'écrivent son nom s'écrit
entre guillemets qui s'écrivent avec des
potentialités la réalité n'est pas du
tout celle ci la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que vanessa derrière elle
l'ensemble de la droite et du centre
monsieur edouard fini qu'il est parti
depuis longtemps il était exclu de notre
parti rappelle donc aujourd'hui il n'est
pas une et pas les républicains il a
fondé son propre parti jusqu'à preuve du
contraire et on voit bien que la
dynamique qui aujourd'hui est la nôtre
elle va trouver tout simplement son sa
résonance tout simplement pourquoi parce
que in fine et les gens qui veulent
battre et macro ils sont nombreux on l'a
encore vu folié faisait référence au jdd
on l'a encore vu le seuls 22% des
français sont aujourd'hui satisfaits de
la politique du gouvernement en matière
de pouvoir d'achat charroux nous avons
des propositions extrêmement concrètes
en la matière notamment sur
l'augmentation des salaires notamment
sur la taxe aux frontières européennes
par rapport à la réciprocité sur les
produits que nous importons est la seule
personne qui concrètement parce que ni
monsieur zemmour ni madame le pen
peuvent envisager de l'emporter au
second tour la seule personne sur lequel
le vote utile peut effectivement et pour
le coup je rejoint ségolène royal peut
effectivement emporté les adhésions
c'est valérie pécresse au second tour
c'est d'ailleurs bien pour ça qu un
torrent de boue et qu'en ce moment
déversées sur elle et ce torrent de boue
il ne faut pas s'y tromper il arrive
d'où il arrive en direct de l'elysée et
de la réplique en marche et puis
également de chez les équipes de zemmour
qui ne sont pas en reste en la matière
fallait se mettre au niveau et les
syndicalistes qu'ils ont pas été tendre
non plus envers envers la candidate 1 je
le rappelle mais non vous pouvez pas
dire ça ce sont des appréciations il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas d'exigence en la
matière nicolas sarkozy a reçu notre
candidate en amont du meeting du zénith
il a reçu longuement il a été
extrêmement agréable avec elle il va
donner un certain nombre de conseils ça
a été dit par l'entourage de nicolas
sarkozy et en la matière moi qui suis
une sarkozyste convaincu que je sais que
nicolas sarkozy ne pourra pas se
départir de sa famille politique donc
les commentateurs commentent et c'est
normal oui et c'est le jeu démocratique
n'est pas de sujets par rapport à ça
mais donnez-moi un nom de sarkozy ce qui
a dit que nicolas sarkozy ne
s'engagerait pas pour valérie pécresse
tout ça c'est faux on verra cela en tout
cas on va parler des parrainages à
présent marine le pen a suspendu sa
campagne de terrain jusqu'à l'obtention
de ces signatures elle a annulé sa
conférence de presse demain sur
l'éducation et son déplacement ce
week-end dans la somme il lui manque un
peu plus d'une quarantaine de paraphes
d'élus locaux et elle a lancé un appel
hier au maire sur les réseaux sociaux
regarder
mesdames et messieurs les maires de
france je m'adresse à vous car je n'ai
pas les parrainages pour être candidate
à la présidence de la république cette
situation est tellement indigne de la
démocratie que des milliers d'entre vous
n'arrive pas à le croire c'est pourtant
vrai il me manque aujourd'hui 50
parrainage comment ce scandale est il
possible alors que ma candidature a
rassemblé plus de 11 millions
d'électeurs au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 dans quelle
république sommes nous pour que je sois
privée de mes parrainages alors que je
suis la principale opposante à emmanuel
macron et que les sondages me donne aux
portes de la victoire pour 2022 arnaud
guven à tam que pensez vous de cet appel
jean luc mélenchon est également
concerné puisqu'il à 442 parrainage à ce
stade david lisnard on l'a vu a même
appelé à l parrainer il le paren lui
même
il donne l'exemple jean castex a lancé
un appel à l'assemblée il ya ça ça
devient critique
non ça ne vient pas critique disons que
c'est un système de parrainage qui à
bout de souffle et effectivement quand
on vois moi je trouve qu'il ya une
hypocrisie bien on va dire les choses
très clairement on remercie les élus qui
quittent qui prennent à raison certaines
ou par année parce que les élus n'ont
pas demandé à avoir ce droit de
parrainage
ils ont ils n'ont pas demandé donc il
faut qu'ils en fassent usage il ya très
peu de très peu d'élus sur le total en
cas passés de parrainer s'ils le font on
peut comprendre pourquoi mais dans tout
ça nous on a avec la france 1 soumise à
l'assemblée utilisé aux parlementaires
pour proposer le parrainage citoyen
c'est à dire que en plus des ou hanche
ou en parallèle les 500 parrainages
d'élus 159 chinois de signatures de
soutien à une candidature par des
citoyens permettait d'accéder à la
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
s'était issue d'un rapport qui était
dirigée par lionel jospin dans lequel
heureusement bachelot a participé à
quelques années on a repris ce chiffre
parce que effectivement autant on pense
qu'il ya la nécessité d'avoir une
respiration démocratique là on se
retrouve dans une situation où on a des
candidats qu'on apprécie qu'on apprécie
pas qu'ils sont au-dessus des 10% qui
sont dans une difficulté à réunir les
parrainages pouvoir se présenter c'est
donc un souci démocratique et pendant ce
temps là à nos militants au lieu de
battre la campagne et de faire valoir
les idées sur la transition écologique
sur la sir la pique nique le partage des
richesses on doit aller convaincre des
mères que en plus on fatigue parce que
les mères ont marre
d'affaires
et oui et donc c'est pour ça que ben
tous ces gens ont voté contre notre
proposition loi qui permettait de régler
un certain nombre de problèmes donc j'en
appelle une nouvelle fois
aux personnes qui sont majoritaires dans
les assemblées fait respirer la
démocratie n ayez pas peur et accepté le
chèque mais des citoyens puissent
parrainer des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
25 il ya 10000 mer sur les 42 mille élus
inquiets qui ont parrainé ce qui reste
assez faible valérie de bord qu'en
pensez-vous sur ce système d'aidé
parrainage il va falloir vraiment
réformer le système d'autant qu'on l'a
vu marine le pen arrête sa campagne ça
prend du temps est ce qu'il faudrait pas
avoir d'abord les parrainages et ensuite
faire campagne ce serait plus logique
il ya un double problème d'ordre dans
cette situation rappelle qu' aucune
difficulté à voir ses parrainages c'est
la première aujourd'hui sur valenciennes
etc territoire le nombre de femmes a
nagé la à 1900
ça traduit aussi une réalité un ancrage
territorial la première chose c'est que
le gouvernement est particulièrement
hypocrite dans cette histoire notamment
avec cette espèce de banques mis en
place monsieur on ne découvre pas que
les parrainages des maires ne sont plus
anonyme c'est monsieur hollande qui a
mis en place cette réforme avec un
objectif assez clair évidemment c'est de
faire en sorte que les extrêmes soient
moins à rennais c'est une évidence
aujourd'hui à officielle parce qu'ils
ont débrayé carrément rida tueur
farfelues oui mais vous savez à partir
du moment où il y avait 12 14
candidatures voilà c'était l'âge et la
démocratie savez gérer cela et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire n'est quand même pas
lui franchement difficulté aujourd'hui
que se passe-t-il le gouvernement arrive
à la rescousse grand seigneur
gouvernement les cinq ans quand même
pour revenir sur cette réforme on ne
découvre pas qu'il va y avoir des
élections présidentielles on ne découvre
pas qui est cette problématique de
parrainage et aujourd'hui on fait
semblant d'être découpé la deuxième
problématique elle et il ya ce que vous
venez dire pareil l'ensemble des
condamnés ne découvre pas qui a ce
préalable des 500 comme guide des 500
signatures un certain nombre de
candidats ont de façon très organisons
préparer leur candidature est présentée
par données très tardivement madame
taubira qui est candidate quand même
depuis très peu de temps il faut quand
même pas que s'étonner complètement
qu'elle ait aussi peu de parrainage une
candidature avec son présidentielle
c'est pas quelque chose qui ne se
prépare pas c'est pas quelque chose qui
s'inscrit pas dans le temps c'est que le
prochain
a toujours pas alors je termine par
rapport à ça madeline open a perdu une
centaine de conseillers régionaux suite
aux dernières élections régionales et
elle même toute franchise d'ailleurs
indiqué qu'ils avaient été assez à
préparer et qu'ils avaient certainement
fait preuve de beaucoup trop optimistes
et qu'il n'avait pas été suffisamment en
amont à la recherche de ses parrainages
in fine est si vous posez la question de
savoir si il ne serait pas normal que
monsieur mélenchon monsieur et madame le
pen ne suis pas candidat bien sûr ce
serait pas normal et il faut qu'il soit
candidat mais néanmoins j'attire quand
même la tension les uns et des autres on
ne peut pas comme systématiquement être
en rappel des uns et des autres le
gouvernement a une grosse part de
responsabilité très clairement ça c'est
très bien de sa l'espère donné comme ça
pour notamment un certain nombre de
candidats donc je crois que il faudra
certainement réforme est ce si ce
dispositif cette banque qui a été créé à
bien ce que ça donnera après encore une
fois quand vous êtes présents sur les
territoires quand vous avez des élus
territoriaux
quand vous êtes en cohérence avec ce que
vous pouvez exprimer bien vous avez
aussi des élus pour vous accompagner
nous sommes dans une démocratie qui est
celui présidentielle qui est à la fois
parlementaires et présidentielle avec un
fort ancrage territorial et cette
réalité là elle doit aussi se
retrouvaient par la candidature des uns
et des autres mais ça veut dire qu'on ne
peut pas avoir de nouveau candidat en
eau vive et natal vous êtes d'accord
avec ça
ça doit aussi été l'ancrage l'ancrage
territorial finalement oui et non parce
que en fait
deux scrutins n'amène pas nécessairement
une représentation des élus qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient
qui correspondent aux résultats des
élections je veux dire aux élections
législatives a fait 12 % il y en a 300
députés donc à un moment donné c'est
effectivement compliqué en terme de
représentativité nos institutions blocs
un certain nombre de choses et que ce
soit l'assemblée ou dans d'autres types
d'élections des scrutins uninominaux à
de tout bas c'est extrêmement compliqué
pour un certain nombre de forces
notamment des nouvelles forces puisque
nous on n'a que 5 ans on va le rappeler
la france oui ça augmente y est jeune
donc l'ancrage territorial c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui s'acquiert
comme ça et pourtant et pourtant c'est
les propositions qui sont partagé par
des millions de concitoyens donc encore
une fois faire respirer la démocratie en
permettant aux citoyens de parrainer et
de permettre à des candidats de
concourir au scrutin de l'élection
présidentielle j'y vois rien de bleus
quand j'y vois même que des solutions
apportées puisque ben là ça fait à peu
près 10 mai comparé les parrainages qui
peut se présenter au nom de quoi de
quelle tradition républicaine qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dépoussiérer qu'est ce qu'il
faut pas dépoussiérés pendant ce temps
là on parle pas des 9 63 euros qu'on
veut donner aux jeunes on parle pas de
on parle pas de défilé et celle des
salaires de 1 à 20 dans les entreprises
on parle pas de comment est-ce qu'on va
affronter la crise climatique
on parle pas tout ça donc à un moment
donné le problème c'est que ça stérilise
ou coup les débats politiques et ça me
permet in fine et pas je trouve d'avoir
un débat présidentiel à la hauteur des
enjeux sur lesquels nos concitoyens nous
attendent
sur des choix essentiels auxquels ils
doivent participer donc
moi je pense effectivement construit
normal de chercher ce qui est la
démocratie merci on a essayé de parler
j'aime pas mais on a vraiment bras des
traditions républicaines c'est comme la
loi voilà c'est la loi c 10
des montants malheureusement on n'avait
pas changé pourquoi tous les dons bercy
d'avoir participé
[Musique]